happy Tuesday everyone so is America's
bad boy everyone already knows that I'm
dangerous
yeah the laugh I'm the Jim Morrison of
talk show hosts and kudlow's My Backdoor
Man
but you know you might be dangerous too
according to the FBI and you don't even
have to be an angry parent to head a
school board meeting you just have to
use words
yeah it turns out New FBI documents
released this week through a foia
request revealed the bureau uses
internet slang to seek out violent
extremism online it's a mix of odd terms
now linked to quote racially or
ethnically motivated violent extremism
words like based LARPing and red pilled
in other words they're terms that could
be used in a context that don't relate
at all to race or extremist views for
example they Define based as someone
who's converted to racist ideology so I
guess they must be keeping a close eye
on Joy Reid right
really doesn't based mean you're based
in facts you're grounded in logic not
wokeness perhaps that's why it's being
targeted then you got LARPing which
stands for live action role play you
know those nerds who dress up as Knights
and wizards until a jock walking through
the park stuffs them in a trash can
but the FBI says LARPing is a term used
by extremists to accuse others of not
being as extreme and I get it my old
manager at Medieval Times used to accuse
me of it when I wouldn't wear a Cod
piece in his hot tub
then there's red pilled the term
obviously came from the classic film The
Matrix but now it's a metaphor for
seeing behind the curtain and uncovering
reality but now becoming red pilled
indicates the adoption of racist
anti-semitic or fascist beliefs so how
did they get there
I don't know but I guess it's a good
thing that I got red pilled way back
when and it wasn't from The Matrix but
The Facts of Life
I am facing it wow
by cutting Gail's classes standing her
up
you can run as far as you want but Gail
is still going to die
[Laughter]
the greatest moment in television
history Gail is going to die
and she did
because that's a fact of life
how could that not change you it changed
me but you could see the danger here
right sure there's extremists out there
who might say they've been red pilled
but some of them also play soccer
it's the mistake the media loves to play
and now the FBI does too they now Define
threats by the weakest of connections so
now you're guilty by word association
maybe that that's why Biden can't
pronounce anything
[Laughter]
speaking of Joe is it me or as the Biden
Administration replaced the role of
Charmin in the White House bathroom with
the Constitution the only right citizens
have these days are those that aren't in
the Constitution I can't own a gun in
New York but I can identify as a chick
and run naked through a Lucille Roberts
locker room
and I have
another part of the FBI document refers
to keeping an eye on in cells which is
short for involuntarily celibate if you
don't know what that is there's your
answer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Mary
but a bunch of the FBI's in cell
terminology words are actually just
slang for example Chad the FBI calls it
the idealized version of a male who is
very successful at getting romantic and
sexual attention from women
that sounds more like a Greg to me
[Laughter]
but if you're a shy dude making fun of
Chads you could end up on a watch list
so just to be safe don't mock hanging
Chads the country Chad or Fox senior
Congressional correspondent Chad pergram
seriously don't let his calm demeanor
fool you I once saw him debone a dolphin
with a violin bow
no reason for it really the feds also
flag a word called look looks maxing
which is defined as the process of
self-improvement with the intent to
become more attractive
well the cast of the view is safe
proving yourself to the mates everyone
does that even Jesse had hair from his
back put on his head
so what is the message here well it's
don't message anything from now on
you're like a mafia Dawn scribbling
notes on torn paper to be eaten later by
a starved underling
it's sad really it's it's almost like
the FBI made its own excuse to spy on
everyone and not just Trump
but it's sadder still that another group
you once looked up to turns out to be
kind of lame you know first it was the
Red Hot Chili Peppers now it's the FBI I
mean I remember you know when you were a
kid working for the FBI sounded cool I
mean they had TV shows and movies about
it from Zimbalist Jr
but what if that was all Bs and it was
always about invasive targeting
informants setups creating criminals out
of misguided fantasists I hope I'm wrong
I mean maybe the New FBI is secretly
based and LARPing until the Chads get
lost now that would be a red pill
let's welcome tonight to guess
he's heard more booze than a haunted
house on Halloween comedian Joe Mackey
she used to interview naked athletes
which means we have a lot in common most
of the sideline sanity podcast Michelle
Tafoya
[Applause]
she's like a bowling alley Extremely
Loud and popular with old men yeah Fox
News contributor cat too
and he uses the Statue of Liberty as a
back scratcher my mess decided to get in
the end
of the enemy champion
you know Joe I wouldn't say you were an
insult but I think the incel kind of
group has embraced you as a leader so
it's not necessarily your fault
but they look up to you for guidance and
they're just waiting for you to say the
word on what they need to do next Greg
not only am I not an insult an in-cell
yes I've been called a stud more times
than Secretariat okay
but I'm not an extremist unless you're
talking about my love of the band
extreme
make the monologue though Greg is that
the FBI has also been going into
Catholic churches and you know trying to
look for for extremists there and I
actually think this is a good thing
maybe they could pay attention while
they're there learn something maybe go
to confession for violating the first
and fourth amendments and then they can
catch the real extremists that are
attacking the churches yes
points
all right Michelle let's I'll play
Devil's Advocate even though I am
definitely not pro Satan Devil's
Advocate is a phrase yes
just want to be clear
what if this is just part of another a
greater focus on grabbing terrorists
that it's just part of something it's
not really like going after normal
people it's just like one little
variable I thought about that too Greg
but then I thought some more ah good
yeah you know the old thing about the
frog in the boiling water so if you take
a frog and you throw it in boiling water
it will immediately jump out because it
senses danger but if you throw a frog
into a pot of tepid water and slowly
turn up the heat it won't notice the
disintegration of its surroundings and
you just keep turning up you boil it and
it's dead
we are the Frog Greg we are the Frog
this country is the Frog I'm sorry we're
the frog is that why you're wearing
green tea this one that's why wearing
green
it's the last time I can be alive does
this all the time at his house in the
Hamptons before I know it I'm like on
fire oh God
kills a lot of germs so the point is is
that little by little they want to
undercut language they want to attack
you for using certain words they also
want to tack words like radical onto the
Catholic religion or what they're
calling it radical Catholicism or
something yeah so they're taking they're
erasing we don't know what a woman is we
have these pronouns being all shifted
around us we are slowly being boiled to
a crisp as a society and it's through
the use of getting rid of language and
then forcing other language on us but I
agree with you hell don't use the you
know those certain terms otherwise it's
a pretext for what do they do next to
you exactly what do they do next I don't
know suddenly I'm just really hungry
you know uh cat um is it what are the
odds that a guy in the FBI would end up
basically you know going after another
person who turns out to be in the FBI it
seems like everybody's an informant at
least on January 6th I think there were
like 40 of them there
yeah and I mean the in-cell thing right
there's plenty of in cells out there
that have disgusting views but just
because you have disgusting views
doesn't mean you're going to do a
terrorism like sometimes you're not
violent or some of these guys like
there's no way they have gas money yeah
like they're just always in my Instagram
comments being like have a baby before
you dry up and
yeah but it's like okay like our like
thanks for the tip you know uh but that
doesn't equal I don't think that they're
actually that concerned about this it's
like an excuse on behalf of the FBI to
Snoop not because the FBI is concerned
but because it's an excuse to Snoop and
actually it's not doesn't make any
difference in terms of safety except
maybe it goes against our safety because
if they have are just this flood of
things they have to look at anyone who
ever used any of these words even
sarcastically or even in another way as
you pointed out they're not going to be
able to focus or maybe even see the
things that are actual threats don't you
feel kind of weird about where a place
talking bad about the FBI because we're
we're at similar ages early 40s you know
I mean the FBI was like a cool thing so
we're teachers I think well they still
are yeah and we need to understand that
it's just that the new regime in is not
and what what happening is is and cat is
right
if you are a Chad first of all as a
Slayer of many in my day I never needed
an abbreviation I knew what I was my
boys knew what I was and I didn't need
to give abbreviations these are they're
changing the language
so that they can justify their violence
so we see it all the time oh when you
don't recognize my pronouns that's
violence against me no no they're trying
to turn sticks and stones will break my
bones names will ever hurt me too names
hurt me so I can use Sticks and Stones
so they're taking our language and
saying that what
everyday normal people say or do is
offensive dangerous racist and violent
so when they participate acts of
violence on us it's Justified like we
saw with the the swimmers she made she
was using her words and she was chased
and attacked and threatened and guess
what they were the victims right because
they were responding to her verbal
violence so they take words that make
zero sense I'm telling you right now Joe
and I when we were hanging and banging
the gym this morning we never once said
never once said hey I said hey Chad yeah
how's your laughing going he would have
he would have slapped me and said
no talk endurance sets Tyrus back to
work we don't use that kind of language
so the real unfortunately are real men
and women in the FBI were trying to do
their job just like our teachers get
overshadowed by the the ones who are
part of this agenda and spend their time
on Tick Tock and look to go after
Everyday People excellent points
up next
female athletes oppose calls to ban
women with balls hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else